John Stamos Brad
p-i-t-t-pit John s t a m o s Stamos pit
Stamos Brad Pitt John Stamo
[Music]
today we are going to be debating who is
the ultimate 90s heartthrob hi I'm Joe
Jonas I'm hyping the 90s heartthrob Brad
Pitt heard of him
my name is Glenn Powell anytime you take
on Brad Pitt it's a hard day but I'm
bringing John Stamos to the table I feel
good about my odds
this debate will have an opening
statement three rounds a final closing
statement and one both flag per side
opening statement who is the ultimate
90s heartthrob and why you have 30
seconds
there's obviously only one major
heartthroat that comes to everyone's in
mind Brad Pitt and here's why
Brad Pitt it's not only a movie star
he's handsome as hell
he's a heartthrob heart
he he covers all the hearts
12 pack 16 pack Maybe
Gorgeous Hair you walk into any salon
now what picture do you see Brad Pitt
because he
you see Brad Pitt you want that haircut
he eats in every movie he still has a
12-pack
you bring up a lot of good points
that was very impressive thank you
you have 30 seconds go
John Stamos is obviously America's
sweetheart America's heartthrob and the
world's throbbing throb the man has been
making the world throb
for all not only a decade he was
throbbing in the 80s he is now throbbing
in the 90s he was America's uncle and
then you had weird feelings for that
Uncle because he was so hot he brought
us a haircut he brought us Uncle Jesse's
guitar and he brought us the fullest of
house and he's making me full house
right now I'm sorry got a little full in
my house if you know what I mean it was
pretty convincing yeah you did bring up
a great point with the 12-pack of it all
I was not thinking about Brad Pitt's abs
yeah that's a whole thing you know he's
had him for quite some time he probably
was born with him do you want to know
how many abs John Stamos has uh not
really but now that you bring it up
please go on I had a shower scene with
John Stamos in a show called scream
Queens so I know how many abs he has and
as many as you can have that's how many
John has
round one Stalin personality this round
is all about the outward perception of
your 90s heartthrob you will have 60
seconds okay let's start at the
beginning
Brad Pitt gorgeous man top of the head
hair lots of it he sometimes had hair
that looked like the significant other
that he was with
his eyes covered in beautiful glasses a
lot of the time
12 packs hiding underneath gorgeous
clothes leather jackets may be worn by
John Stamos who knows
beautiful pair of pants always worn
ripped denim owned them
you know this guy you've seen him on
covers of magazines you've seen him on
posters of buildings
he is created by God and God said you're
welcome world
this is the man we all need to be
Brad Pitt also he has got fangs in that
one movie aesthetically gorgeous
can you name another sexy uh Tom Cruise
God damn it there's a lot of sexy
vampires
you went with the
are there any other sexy vampires
we're gonna talk about a man of style
we're going to start with John Stamos
that man brought us the fluffiest mullet
in the history of time
we would be nowhere
in terms of hair without John Stamos
he came through the door of the Full
House and he brought us Uncle Jesse and
he brought us it looked like a baby
chick at first it was just like adorably
beautiful and then you realized it was
raw sex that's what John Stamos brought
us with that haircut in terms of style
we also have the leather jacket
that leather jacket was gone nobody was
wrapping leather jackets it's seen some
years it was gone though it was it was
iconic at one point and then people gave
up on the leather jacket and here comes
John Stamos Uncle Jesse in the basement
with his band wearing the leather jacket
and my God we felt things we hadn't felt
in years
God damn it John you're so good your
style your personality it shines through
and I'm so lucky you were born
[Music]
John Stamos is going to call you after
this
round two body of work this round is all
about the decade defining work of your
90s heartthrob what makes your choice
emblematic of the 90s you have 60
seconds to make your argument there are
so many iconic Brad Pitt movies I mean
where to begin
from the 90s alone
got Fight Club let's start there
glistening six-pack 12-pack 18 pack 30
pack okay
the guy was willing to chip his tooth
for the roll so he's he's in it he's in
it Legends of the Fall riding beautiful
horses
crying his eyes out showing raw emotion
take notes Glenn Powell
seven
insanity
and he held it together
Thelma and Louise
it's one of my favorites
gorgeous hitchhiker
I mean where do we go where do we go
from here I don't know nominated how
many times
Brad Pitt has all all of it
also
other movies that I can't remember right
now Brad Pitt's amazing
red light means I'm almost out can you
name how many John Stamos movies can you
name Glenn Powell
there is not a more iconic TV show of
the 90s than Full House
so nice we had to do it twice Full House
Fuller house
but let's go back to the OG
John Stamos
Uncle Jesse
America's uncle
he made Hot music in a basement with his
band and his wife loved it
Aunt Becky arguably
the most iconic woman of the 90s as well
they're a power couple think about that
in one house with the Olsen twins need I
say more and they lived in our homes
every week John Stamos lived in my house
with my family we ate dinner together
what a concept where's Brad Pitt been
does Brad Pitt eat dinner with your
family
I don't think so
John Stamos is part of the Powell family
[Music]
I've had dinner with John Stamos have
you I have I'm about to pull this flag
right now Google it
give me my give me my flag [ __ ] on
YouTube is that right you can't double
[ __ ] I can do it that's not how it
works somebody gets me picks up this
dinner I'm sorry I'm sorry I just don't
buy it I don't buy it at this dinner it
happened it happened many times
time that we've been Googling this there
are no photos of Joe Jonas and John
Stamos
Glenn Powell wins the [ __ ]
Google never lies
Joseph Jonas round three the test of
time this round is all about the
cultural significance and Legacy of your
heartthrob has your 90s heartthrob stood
the test of time you have 60 seconds to
State your case
Brad Pitt
didn't win sexiest man of the year once
he won it twice
in 1995 People magazine called him the
sexiest man alive
in 2000 something he also was called the
sexiest man alive
that is a pretty damn impressive that's
pretty cool
he also
constantly looks good
bullet train Premiere flawless I want to
know what he was wearing what were those
glasses how does his hair stay in place
when he's doing those twirl jumps
guy takes off his clothes it's like he's
never aged
what does he do what's his workout
routine what does he eat
I want to know he doesn't just ride
motorcycles around and get fit he's got
to be working out right he's stand the
test of time and he will always stand
the test of time I heard him say in an
interview he's getting into that era
where he's the older man and see in the
movies I disagree Brad
you keep showing us your sexy bod
because I'll keep buying movie tickets
[Music]
I will say
Brad Pitt in a kilt was unexpectedly
heartthrobby
I didn't know that was inside of me and
when he did the Twirl in The Kilt killed
me dad I agree kill me Daddy
all right Glenn round three
keep up
you have 60 seconds on the clock to
State your case when we talk about aging
well
there are two words we use it is John
sometimes with a word in the middle and
Stamos
he is defying time the man looks so so
good it's unbelievable Stamos has the
secret of Youth running through his
veins and my God we are lucky for it I
don't feel like I've aged a day every
time I look in his eyes when my family's
having dinner with him
I say my gosh you look as good as you
did in the 90s John
and not to bring up the aforementioned
shower scene that I did with John where
I did see
his lower Stamos my God that has an H
today either
still looks as good as the 90s
and not to bring up the unlimited ABS he
has we didn't see it in the 90s
how's television family television thank
you very much
all this Brad Pitt talk
hahaha
closing argument this is your last
chance to defend your ultimate 90s
heartthrob make your final statement for
why your heartthrob owned the decade you
will have 30 seconds I want to start
with a compliment I love John Stamos
he's a handsome fellow he owned
television I will give that to you Brad
Pitt however
he's owned a lot of lives
he is the man of Hearts he carries those
hearts his Jar of Hearts he has my heart
Glenn he has your heart and you know it
you've been lying to my face this whole
damn time he's a superstar he's a movie
star he's also charitable the guy he was
donating things I saw it on TMZ guy has
a heart of gold
and I want to be Brad Pitt and I know
you do too
the hell of a closing argument
you are absolutely right Brad Pitt is
the sexiest man alive in two decades
he's unbelievable
he's unbelievably sexy I can't even wrap
my head around how sexy he is I've
modeled my whole look after him clearly
but guess what John Stamos is an icon
John Stamos comes in with a sex appeal
that existed in decades past he sends us
time traveling every time I see his face
I can't help myself John Stamos has
everything and I know he has every bit
of you too
that was great
and you're right
John Stamos does have my heart
a little tiny tiny mini door inside of
it
because the rest is covered in pictures
of Brad Pitt you open that door
you make that door a little bit bigger
there is room for pit and stainless here
[Music]
I mean I Gotta Give it to Glenn he's
very convincing and I definitely want to
go research a lot of things about John
Stamos that I won't say here in this
room
but I have to say I think I carry the I
carry the torch here that's why I
brought Brad Pitt and John Stamos here
right now I'm just kidding can you
imagine John Stamos just comes in and
knocks you out right now you bring up so
many good arguments in terms of Brad but
do I find him to be a 90s heartthrob
he didn't guide me into the 90s
John Stamos did I think we can agree to
disagree and then we'll agree and
disagree again I don't know where we are
right now I don't know who we are right
now my heart's beating so fast right now
just thinking about these two dudes
laughs it's been my pleasure Glenn power
it is my pleasure Joe Jonas put her
there